it is
television is abuzz with the drama
surrounding Saint longest-running
television singing competition oh those
fateful light in the hands of whoever
takes over this once hit series how do I
keep coming on these shows cut to
commercial everybody just assumed the
station would be taking over she's
worked for years for this I have a big
oh no I'm the new executive producer of
singer how could you hire someone with
no TV experience to take over my show
experience is overrated and I can tell
you that from experience meet Luke your
new assistant
this is Jackie different please show
them around so what he's blind I'm not
deaf mother oh excuse me Jackie this is
going to be good go kill em tiger now
comes everyone's favorite parts where we
crush more dreams they're gonna sing it
is too much about the it and it needs to
be more about the same
destiny is calling when didi you kid out
of rehab this is gonna be the worst
season ever
as my stepmother Ted used to say let's
not squander the opportunity and let's
not tell mom